foreign
do you have any heretical beliefs
about
Consciousness that
people in the space would strongly
disagree with or think are unfounded yet
you have some degree of conviction in
yes all right if people are interested
in this I have a more long form
presentation of of a talk I gave at the
in Thunder Bay of the conference on
Consciousness and conscience I talk
about the three questions of
consciousness
and so the first question is the
question everybody's really fixated on
which is the nature question which is
how is something that seems so
non-physical how does it possibly exist
in
the otherwise physical universe and
that's the nature question and of course
you have Chalmers version of the hard
problem and qualia and things like that
I'll come back to qualia in a second
now there's another question which is as
equally important and P and people don't
give it enough
attention and they should and this is
the function question which is what is
consciousness for what does it do
and before you give me an answer let me
try and make this more problematic to
you you do a lot of very very
sophisticated stuff without
Consciousness you are taking the noises
coming out of my face hole and
translating them into ideas in your mind
and you have no idea how that process
works you have no introspective access
to it right right
I make noises you have ideas what's
happening in between don't know right
yeah or think about the complex
sophisticated action you can do how
little attention you have to bring to
walking or even and you've had this I no
doubt probably Highway hypnotism where
you've been driving and and you realize
for the past 50 I haven't been paying
attention to the road at all and yet
this sort of philosophy this sort of
zombie inside me has been managing me to
keep me on the road and this right and I
wouldn't rely on it or anything but you
did right so
the question is we seem to be able to
our unconscious seems to be so powerful
what why do we have Consciousness what's
it do and why do we love it so much yeah
right
and then the third question is the meta
question what's the relationship between
these questions so here's my first
heresy
unlike many people I think these two
questions have to be answered in a
completely integrated fashion I think
trying to answer the nature question
without answering the function question
is doomed to fail and I think trying to
answer the function question without
trying to answer the nature question is
doomed to fail so there's the first
vervecan heresy and I don't know who
who's going to be devil's advocate for
me but anyways I know that'd be the
opposite of that to be the person
putting me on trial
so that's the first here's the second
the second is
we can do this
we can find
a way of answering this
if we pay attention to a convergence
that is occurring about what is the
function of Consciousness and then I
think this gives us a lot of the
machinery for explaining a lot of the
qualia
that are so Central to the nature of
consciousness qualia
being qualia means the subjective feel
the redness of red to you it's not just
you're not just unconsciously reacting
to wavelengths you're having this
experience of redness that's a qualia
and that seems to be something in
Consciousness and it's subjective in
nature and we don't even know if you're
calling my qualia are the same right
very often they're not right
I mean Japan is a good example of that
right I mean they're like green and blue
are not the same green and blue that we
see depending on you know the the the
crosswalk go signals and so on and even
a person who's colorblind right has
different quality or is Thomas Nagel
famously argued bats who use
echolocation have qualia that we don't
have yeah right right okay so that's
what that means and that's the hard
problem because there doesn't seem to be
any way of explaining
their nature but I think if you get into
and this is work I'm doing with a whole
bunch of other people so I don't want to
take sole credit but I think if you make
use of functionality and you make use of
the four kinds of knowing and things
like this I think you can give an
integrated answer there is a consensus
emerging and I've published on this and
talked about this around what
Consciousness does what's it for and
then I think once you get that and you
open up that functionality you actually
get a phenomenology you get an you get
an explanation of the experience out of
that so the converging thing is that
what Consciousness is for and it
overlaps with attention and working
memory and fluid intelligence
think about when you're driving on the
highway when do you come back to it if
there's something unexpected happens or
there's a really complex situation
suddenly emerging or there's an
ill-defined problem that you're not
quite sure how to formulate and frame
that's what you need Consciousness for
so what is consciousness it's this
higher order relevance realization it's
about
re-realizing what's relevant and
important so that you can deal with the
added challenge of zeroing in on
relevant information that is given to
you by novelty complexity and
ill-definedness that's what
Consciousness for it's this it's
enhanced relevance realization that's
why it overlaps with working memory and
things like that now that does sound
like a Consciousness that would extend
to animals other than
humans totally it helps to explain our
intuition about this generally when
people are willing to extend the
attribution of Consciousness they
actually do it in a way without
realizing that tracks how much fluid
intelligence
do they think that organism has because
fluid intelligence working memory
attention all of these things are about
relevance realization and enhancing it
and so you've got this consensus okay
but let's say we get relevance
realization
and that consciousness of higher order
version what about qualia
well first of all let's divide qualia
and this is this is the second verveiki
heresy let's divide qualia into two
kinds of qualia
there's the typical quality that
philosophers love to talk about the
adjectival qualia like blueness and
greenness and sweetness but there are
adverbial qualia there are qualias of
keenness nowness togetherness of my
experience I'm here I'm now my
experience is together there's a unity
and a here now presence uh presencing of
Consciousness the adverbial
now here's the thing
here's the thing
talk to people who have engaged in
long-term meditative practice and this
is well documented read Foreman for the
documentation I've I've been here in
this state and you get into a state
called the pure Consciousness event
you're not conscious of anything you're
definitely not conscious of inequality
you're not conscious of any thought
you're not even conscious of
Consciousness you're just conscious
you don't black out you're just
conscious you all you have is a pure
perspectival participatory knowing of
con you're conscious by being conscious
and there's nothing else going on
and what's interesting about that is you
don't black out because you can remember
being there in that state there's no
adjectival qualia but Consciousness is
still present
so think about that for a second but
what doesn't go away you don't live you
don't lose the hereness because people
say in the pure Consciousness event I
was fully there's full presence
right you don't lose nowness they talk
about I mean eternity this pure nouness
and they don't talk they don't lose
togetherness they talk about pure
Oneness and unity
the adverbial qualia are on steroids and
the adjectival qualia have gone away
yeah that's interesting it's a good way
to put it the adjectival qualia are not
necessary and there's other arguments
they're not sufficient for Consciousness
Consciousness is primarily about
adverbial qualia and a verbal qualia can
be explained by relevance realization
it's how are things relevant to you that
gives you Ascent the centeredness to
consciousness
how the timing of things is an important
part of relevance how things belong
together fit together that's relevance
realization gives you the adverbial
qualia so if you understand the
functionality of Consciousness as
heightening
relevance realization it will be present
in all of those adverbial qualia and
there will be a sense of those even
being heightened when you're in a pure
Consciousness State that's the third and
last for vaky heresy so it's a
completely naturalistic explanation of
consciousness